late for visitors isn't it huh
oh well yeah honey but these boys just
got out of joint
so we got to show a little hospitality
well now
h.i looks like you've been up to the
devil's business
hey is that a hammer or her
it's a little boy
got a name does he uh so far we've just
been using junior we call him junior
you mean you mean j.r just like tv show
oh tom what's the rumpus mink see you
got your hat back
yeah whatever i think tom look if any of
my business i got not a thing to say
listen bernie wants to see what's
important
yeah well i'm right here i'm not made a
glass yeah but he's nervous walking
around in public time he's the right guy
he's very nervous i mean who wouldn't be
luckily i mean the spot he's in who
wouldn't be he asked me to ask you to
ask lu to take care of him you know
putting a good word with leo leo listens
to you not that leo wouldn't help the
shmot anyway you kinda like bernie
squared you like the shimano straight
shooter like him i don't get it mike
who wants to get us as plain as the nose
on your face i thought you were already
dancing sick at first
yeah tom that's right but a guy could
have more than one fan kenny i mean not
that i want a damn to know about it but
squedgey liked the shimano he's the
right guy time he's a square shooter i
know he's got a mixed reputation but for
ashini he's got a lot of good qualities
what's going on between you and
nothing tom we're just friends you know
when he goes
what do you got for me what the hell
happened to your face all right no
nothing it's just a mosquito bite ah
like hell it is you know mosquitoes in
los angeles mosquitoes breeding swamps
this is a desert
what do you got for me well i i'm the
beery picture where are we what do you
got
well i'm i'm having a little trouble
getting started eating stuff
christ jesus started you mean you don't
have anything yet well not much
what the hell do you think this is
hamlet going with the
wind ruggles a red it's a goddamn bee
picture
big men in tights you know the drill i'm
afraid i don't really understand that
genre maybe that's the problem
just understand i thought you were going
to consult another writer on this
well i've talked to bill maybe bill may
may you somehow the guy's a sausage he's
a great writer a great sauce you don't
understand
stuff same because he can't write sauce
right he manages to write his name on
the back of his paycheck every week
but i thought no one cared about this
picture who thought where the hell did
you get that from you thought
listen i don't know what the hell you
said to lipnick but the son of a
likes you you understand that think he
lights you up he's taken
a interest do you mind if i sit down
carrying a bit of a load here
no yeah it's this vehicle i asked you
about yesterday i was just wondering
yeah like i told you we haven't had any
vehicles go missing
okay are you sure because i mean
how do you know because the crime i'm
investigating the perpetrators were
driving a car with dealer plates
and they called someone who works here
so it'll be quite a coincidence if they
weren't you know
connected yeah i see so
how do you have you done any kind of
inventory recently
the car is not from our lot man but how
do you know that for sure without doing
that
well i would know i'm the executive
sales manager
yeah but i understand we run a pretty
tight chip here
i know but well how do they establish
that sir i mean are the cars counted
daily or what kind of a routine here
ma'am i answered your question
i'm sorry sir ma'am i answered your
question
i answered the darn i'm cooperating here
and there
there's no uh
sir you have no call to get snippy with
me i'm just doing my job here
i'm i'm not
uh i i'm not arguing here i'm
cooperating
and there's no we're doing all we can
are you employing mr lebowski wait let
me let me explain something to you
um i am not mr lebowski you're mr
lebowski
i'm the dude so that's what you call me
you know
uh that or uh his dudeness or
uh duder or uh you know el dorino
if you're not into the whole brevity
thing uh are you employed sir
employed you don't go out looking for a
job dressed like that do you
on a weekday is this a
what day is this well i do work sir
so if you don't mind well i do mind uh
the dude minds this will not stand
you know this aggression will not stand
man
damn we're in a tight spot what in the
sam hill
pete's cousin turned us in for the
bounty the hell you say
walsh's kim sorry pete i know we're kim
but
they got this depression on all got to
do for me and mine
i'm gonna kill you judas iscariot
hogue you miserable all seating
damn we're in a tight spot you got no
cause to hurt me no
but i gave my word you gave your word
to your husband
that don't make sense you
gave your word to my husband to kill me
your husband had the opportunity to save
you
instead he used you to try to save
himself
not like that
not like you say
you don't have to do this people always
say the same thing
what do they say they say you don't have
to do this
you don't i couldn't call you when
you're totally on secure phone but
i know who the guy is the guy
the guy the secret guy
so is he high up uh i don't know if he's
hot probably
i mean i got his name not his rank so
what's his name
osborne cox never heard of him
oh like you're so plugged into the
intelligence i'm just saying it's a
label
i think the quality of the intelligence
dictates how high up he is
not what we know i also do
do you have any water i gotta hydrate i
got tap water
are you kidding how do you know who he
is
sources what do you mean sources you got
like gatorade or
anything besides like maryland swamp
what do you know how far this is from
how do you know his name i got this geek
friend eddie gallegos he does computer
stuff
hooks up people's computers and programs
your vcrs and
so he examines the files and pulls off
the digital watermark which
tells you what computer it was created
on child's play for eddie
uh-huh and i got his number
i got his number oh my god that was a
bit more difficult
should we give him a tinkle oh my god
sai and i
think it's best if you move out of the
house
move out well it makes eminence sad
things can't continue
move out where would i go oh for
instance the jolly roger is quite
livable it's not expensive
the rooms are eminently habitable this
would allow you to visit the kids
there's convenience in its favor they've
got a pool wouldn't it make more sense
for you to move in with psy
harry larry you
you are jessica i think really
the jolly roger is the appropriate
course of action
your name is maddie but you're a little
maddie the bookkeeper
isn't that something yes and i know you
tom cheney
you're going out here coming to fetch
some water oh man what are you doing in
these mountains here
well i have not been formally deputized
but i'm acting as an agent for marshall
ruben cochran and judge parker's court
i have come to take you back to fort
smith
well i will not go how do you like that
there's a posse of officers up there who
will force you to go a lot is
interesting news
and how many is up there right around
50.
and they're all well armed and they mean
business what i want you to do now is
come on across the tree come on in front
of me up that hill
i think i will oblige the officers to
come after me
so if you refuse to go i'll have to
shoot you
oh well you'd better [ __ ] your piece
all the way back locked
i know how to do it you will not go with
me
no it's just the other way around you're
going with me
you know a doctor right yes
from when whatever diane
yes and you'll pay for it yes
don't tell jim obviously
i should have had you wear double
condoms
well we shouldn't have done it in the
first place but if you ever do it again
which is a favor to women everywhere you
should not
but if you do you should be wearing
condom on condom and then wrap it in
electrical tape
you should just walk around always
inside a great big condom because you
are sh
okay you should not be in contact with
any living thing being
have you ever heard the expression it
takes two to tango
[Music]
you